let us now introduce the linear least
mean squares formulation the setting is
the usual one we have an unknown random
variable and another random variable
which is our observation we are giving
enough information so that we can for
example calculate the Joint Distribution
of these two random variables what we
would like to do in the least squares
methodology is to come up with an
estimator such that the mean squared
error of this estimator is as small as
possible and we have seen the general
solution to this problem if we consider
arbitrary estimators it turns out that
the best possible estimator the best
possible function G is this particular
function of the observations our
estimator is the conditional expectation
of theta given X now let us look at an
example that we considered earlier
suppose that X and theta have a joint
PDF which is uniform over this
particular region we did consider this
example and we found that the optimal
estimator was a function that had this
particular shape so this blue curve here
corresponds to the function which is the
conditional expectation of theta given
the value of the observation that we
have obtained we notice that this
function is nonlinear but it is only
mildly nonlinear the fact that it is
nonlinear is a little bit of a nuisance
it makes it somewhat of a complicated
function wouldn't it be nicer if our
estimator had turned out to be a linear
function of the data such as this one it
would have been nicer but unfortunately
that's not the case
but what if we impose it as a constraint
that we will only look at estimators
that are linear functions of the data
what does that mean mathematically
speaking it means that we will only
consider estimators that depend linearly
on the data X now a and B
our serve parameters that are for us to
choose if I choose a and B differently
I'm going to get a different red curve
here which one is the best red curve
well we need a criterion but let us
stick to our mean squared error
criterion and in that case we are led to
the following formulation we want to
find choices for a and B that is we want
to choose a particular red line so that
the resulting estimation error the
resulting mean squared estimation error
is small as possible so what we have
here is the random variable here is the
value that's going to be given to us by
your estimator and we look at the
Associated error square it and take the
expectation so this is the linear least
mean squares formulation we're looking
for an estimator which is a linear
function of the data and we want to
choose the best possible linear function
how does it compare to the earlier
problem of picking the best estimator
here we were considering an arbitrary
function G and we were trying to find
the best possible function of the data
which would be our estimator so this was
really an optimization over all possible
functions here we only have an
optimization with respect to two numbers
so at least mathematically this should
be a simpler problem and we will see
that it has a simple solution before
going on to the solution however let me
make one comment that in some cases the
linear least squares estimation problem
is relatively easy to solve and these
are the cases where the conditional
expectation turns out to be linear in
the data this is the best possible
estimator if it happens to be linear
it's at least as good as any other
linear estimator so it's also going to
be the optimal linear as
mater that is if the optimal solution
turns out to be already linear by
imposing the extra constraint of
sticking to linear estimators is not
going to make any difference but for the
general case in general this is not
going to be the case the conditional
expectation may well turn out to be a
nonlinear function of the data as in
this example and in those cases the
linear least mean squares estimator is
going to turn out to be different